welcome back okay
in the last few lectures we've been
talking about eigen system realization
algorithm which is a very versatile and
powerful data-driven tool if I have
impulse response data from a system if I
can kick the system and measure the
outputs I can build a reduced order
model a low dimensional model that best
captures those input output dynamics and
then I can use that model for prediction
and control okay
this is a great method I use it all the
time and it's now scalable you can run
it on huge systems but it's
fundamentally based on this assumption
that I can get an impulse response for a
system okay that is actually harder to
do than you might think
so how would you get an impulse response
for a system you care about like let's
say I have a mass on a spring okay and I
want to give this and I can I can move
the base an impulse response might be
just to jerk your hand up and down as
fast as possible or build a motor to do
that okay you can build an impulse
response for that super simple system
what if I want to characterize my car
okay what is an impulse response for
that do I just like gun it on the gas
and then let up well that might not give
me a lot of information
maybe my you know the system is a little
bit unresponsive so in some cases and
maybe I have noise maybe this is
actually maybe the biggest issue is
maybe I have an impulse but really I
have like a noisy measurement I've got a
lot of noise on top of this and so I
don't have a reliable impulse response I
could do you know 20 impulse responses
and average the results all kinds of
things can go wrong
maybe my system is not entirely linear
maybe it's like mostly linear but
there's some nonlinear stochastic stuff
happening all kinds of reasons why you
might get a crappy impulse response and
need to use something else so there's a
more powerful add-on to this called the
observer observer calman filter
identification observer Kuhlman filter
identification
it's called okay ID and I think this was
developed in the 90s
let's just say 90s by a bunch of people
summit Princeton summit Langley the
names that come to my mind are fan and
long men but I'm sure there were many
others okay very interesting sorry this
is hard to read observer calman filter
identification identification but if you
have noisy tough data you can't do an
impulse response you take that data you
first hit it with okay ID and then you
hit it with er a okay so what okay ideas
is it takes kind of pseudo-random
input-output data so now I have like you
know maybe I just I can force my system
with some kind of pseudo-random data and
I get some you know some corresponding
output response in in Y whatever you and
Y are pseudo random input and then the
system output what okay ID does maybe I
should drop down here what OK ID does is
it estimates kind of an optimal calman
filter estimator of what the impulse
response would have been that is most
consistent with this input-output data
for non impulse responses so I think
about this really in terms of a
schematic there is some heavy math under
the hood of observer common filter
identification it's a very cool idea to
optimally estimate what the best impulse
response would have been actually really
or your optimally estimating what these
matrices are that's most consistent with
this input-output data and then you can
use those measurements with the ER a to
get a reduced order model okay so it's a
this is kind of if you have if you can't
do an impulse response or you have
really noisy data or it takes a really
long time for it to decay to zero the
first you could first you observe our
common filter and then do I consistent
realization algorithm so you can give it
pseudo-random rich input data kick the
system you know maybe hit the gas and
different you know hold it down for a
second let go hold it down for two
seconds let go for three seconds you
know get a pseudo-random input measure
the outputs get your impulse response
estimate
and then run it through a re that's the
procedure okay this is probably about as
deep down the rabbit hole as we're gonna
get in this entire modern data-driven
control lecture series you know we've
already gone from linear system
identification to balanced models to
balance truncation to eigen system
realization to observer comment I mean
this is like many layers deep in terms
of bringing out heavier and heavier guns
to solve harder and harder problems so
if you have noisy hard to measure
lightly damped dynamics you might do
okay ID followed by er a if you're
starting to feel overwhelmed skip this
lecture and go to the MATLAB demo where
we actually play around with this stuff
or even skip that entirely and go to
some of the nonlinear system ID lectures
DMD Koopmans Cindy those are kind of the
modern methods this is the classic
history you know and this does fit in
but but I feel like I have to tell you
that it's very interesting and very
powerful okay I'm not going to show you
how the entire okay ID works it is based
on this idea that you can use a common
filter to estimate these matrices from
this data and then you can use these
matrices with er a to get a system model
that's how it was developed I guess what
I want to show you is roughly how the
math would look okay so I'm going to do
this let's see I'll do this in green so
remember how we did an impulse response
to get these I literally said you equals
the identity and then at zero at all
other times and I get these that's what
we're gonna do here but now U is not
simple U is changing at every time step
okay so what I'm going to do we're going
to assume that there's a system XK plus
1 equals a XK plus bu k and YK equals C
XK plus d UK and what I'm going to do is
just like before I'm gonna see what
happens with you X this is going to take
a lot of space and why
for various you know k0 k1 k2 and so on
and so forth okay so as time increases
what happens to to the state and to the
measurements why okay so the unfortunate
thing is this is not just a delta I have
to call this u 0 u 1 u 2 u 3 dot dot dot
dot and I have to figure out what the
system response is for this this series
of pseudo random inputs okay okay we
assume that X 0 is 0 and so y 0 is just
D times u 0 that's simple
okay but now at time 1 X 1 is B times u
0 so that's B times u 0 and so y 1 is C
times B times u 0 but now plus D times u
1 because this is not zero anymore so
plus D times u 1 you can already see
this is going to get more complicated
than the RA okay time to this is my
state at time 1 so my state at time 2 is
a B u 0 plus B times u 1 yeah it's
getting worse okay I'm just gonna work
down here next time it's going to be a
squared B u 0 plus a B u 1 plus B u 2
and so on and so forth so every time
step I pick up another term because I
have another little Delta u kicking the
system this thing is being constantly
forced this is getting worse and worse
and then the Y's are also getting
nastier and nastier so now I have C a B
u naught plus C B u 1 plus D u 2 and so
on and so forth CA squared B you're not
you can kind of get the pattern here
plus C a B u 1 plus CB u 2 Plus D u 3 so
the long story short is that now the
impulse response was really convenient
because the output Y was simple there
was only one term
per time step whereas here because I'm
constantly forcing the system I'm
getting the convolved the convolution of
all of these little forcings and that's
building up I mean the a matrix this the
effect of these might be decaying this
might be less important after 100
iterations but it's still in the math
okay it's still there and so this is
where it gets kind of interesting is I
can take this expression and I can write
down all of these Y's this is just you
know y0 y1 y2 blah blah blah u0 u1 u2
blah blah blah and what I can do you're
gonna have to kind of take my word for
it so I don't have enough space to
really show all of this is that you can
write y 0 Y 1 y 2 dot dot dot dot dot
equals D CB CA B dot dot dot dot dot
times this giant matrix of u 0 u 1 u 2
dot dot dot 0 u 0 u 1 dot dot dot 0 0
you get the picture not that dot so this
is kind of upper triangular matrix of
all of my use u not on the diagonal you
want on the next diagonal u2 on the next
one u3 u4 u5 and the idea is if I
multiply this out let's just kind of do
this example so y 0 equals D times u 0
check Y 1 equals D times u 1 plus C B
times u 0 check Y 3 equals these three
terms times those three terms check so
you get the idea here what I've done is
I've said my measured Y so I this is
data okay this is data this is data I
have I know what my u is and I know what
my Y is this is my impulse response this
is the thing I want okay all of this
impulse response
matrices that's this matrix here that's
what I want so basically what okay I D
does is it's an optimal way kind of
knowing that there's gonna be noise and
disturbances in your system it's an
optimal way knowing that this and this
are both going to be noisy and bad and
corrupted of kind of inverting this U
matrix and solving for this impulse
response it's kind of this this
denoising pseudo inverse using a common
filter that solves for the impulse
response that's under that that's at
least at the big picture what's
happening you have this continuously
forced system you can write down what
that would look like if it was linear
you can formulate that in terms of these
data matrices in terms of data you have
and the thing you want and then this
algorithm basically is a procedure for
solving for this in a way that is kind
of optimal with respect to noisy crappy
data okay in the next lecture we're
going to code these up we're gonna play
around with them I'm going to show you
you'll have all of this code so you can
go through and try it out on your own
systems but you understand at least kind
of the high-level view of what okie idea
is doing to augment er a if it's hard to
get an impulse response or if you have
noisy data we're gonna code it up next
time and that's going to be it for the
linear system idea thank you